the Joe Rogan experience being a
comedian then also been funny in person
that a little bit of different it's
different yeah there's some people just
they're just funny like Richard Jeni
who's in my mind one of the best
comedians of all time
he was always real somber in person like
never it was never really serious he's
depressed which is why I killed himself
just wasn't happy
this wasn't it's kind of a bone his own
skin and there's comedians like that now
even at this story where you meet him
you're like oh wow you're you're very
serious about Brody you know bro do you
mean there wasn't that serious with
least around me the few times when I was
around him he he was fun he would get
dark who get dark I don't know enough
I'm not gonna pretend I did he was
always very cool yeah I mean I think
guys like you and I one thing especially
coming from athletics coming from
martial arts you're you're more likely
to like suck it up and you're more
likely to not give in to the negative
demons and you're also more likely to
exercise regularly you're more likely to
so when you see someone who's struggling
with something they shouldn't be
struggling with you like but you're good
for frustrating hey you're good that's
right why you bummed out you're [ __ ]
you're really good like if you are doing
really good as a comic you know you'll
call me up and you're psyching killed
tonight it was amazing I had such a
great sentiment that's great that's
awesome yeah it's not bragging no no no
no it's happiness is happy I tell you
because I know you relate to it so Brody
who was a murderer you could never say
he was great you could never say like
Brody [ __ ] kill me if he would like
to skirt around it like Rogen always
supportive Rogen
yeah they always got my back yeah so it
was would always deflect it
he never I don't think he wanted to do I
don't think he wanted to accept the fact
that people loved him like when you know
when he had would have a great set would
almost like it wouldn't elevate him like
some guys get off stay like Hinchcliffe
Hinchcliffe a murderer get off stage
will be like the car-service eyes would
be giant I'll high-five everybody he's
feeling it you know but Brody didn't get
like that and I'm not saying Theo is the
same in any regard to what Brody was
suffering with but you know Theo has his
demons whatever you need to be
it's out there I'm not outing feels the
same way where he'll do a set I'm like
do that some of the best things I've
ever seen man I'm like get the [ __ ] stop
get the [ __ ] yeah Tony it's so good dude
it's a version of it me ratios got his
own version it's not as extreme if it
has they're monsters yeah but I like a
guy like you or me
we're very you're goal-oriented you see
you're trying to get better at things
you see things that's how you got good
at Jiu Jitsu so you got good at fighting
so you get a good at comedy everything
you want to get good at you get good at
by focusing on it and setting goals and
trying to get better and better and when
you do get better you celebrate you
enjoy it's fun it's exciting some people
don't get that feeling man they don't
they don't ever get those highs those
highs just don't exist